j'ai carrément du corps les lie
jusqu'à 28 du volet santé
je la com d'agglo québécois puis la
candidate pour le parti du candidat pour
le parti libéral du canada je suis la
candidate pour le npd pour les élections
fédérales
si vous êtes de la région où la terre
cette pré-campagne les commencer puis
dire pour vous c'est que ça a commencé
en février en avril on avait déjà
commencé à bâtir notre équipe ait
commencé sur le terrain
pour moi ç'a commencé le 23 mai a été
investi le 22 mai 23 mètres sur le
terrain la campagne commencée depuis le
moigne et vous allez intéressés par la
campagne
ces matériaux remise en état c'est le
fédéral louis - les élections à vie je
suis vous avez vous la faites de la
politique vous avez la tête à la danse
le c'est l'été les gens ont la tête aux
vacances fait pas la politique tanxxx
dans ce contexte le seco la stratégie la
stratégie c'est que c'est quand même
l'année électorale si sûr que les gens
sont pas encore là dedans non les
approches on leur demanda tout d'abord
est ce que vous savez que les élections
qui s'en viennent et c'est drôle parce
que moi je m'attendais à ce que moins de
gens soient au courant oui soyons pas la
tête à la politique mais la politique
c'est un peu tout le temps c'est l'art
de vivre ensemble ces jeunes abordent
pas avec ce sujet l'omi m'en parle plus
que que moi je peux en parler
l'idée c'est de pas fondées sur les gens
avec des enjeux spécifiquement vient pas
d'en vendre notre salade
après l'escale que nous avons une
discussion savoir sk des questions sont
importants pour reprendre la tente de se
présenter ou slaves et merci c'est
gentil
ah ouais
gagner avec moi votre opinion est déjà
fait
ce signal partie venir voir ça changera
pas on verra mais un muscadet à vous de
voir que les candidats sont déjà sur le
terrain c'est raide et même au mois
d'août vous en pensez quoi
pincez moi je trouve ça formidable au
moins on n'a pas les connaître de plus
en plus mais moi avant septembre ou
alors je veux rien savoir des élections
c'est quand les élections fédérales à 21
octobre on est près du terrain mon avis
même parlé avec les citoyens puissent
exprimer leurs idées
je pense que la question de la
souveraineté se dessine aux élections
fédérales que pas de vote acquis pour
personne les gens sont prêtes à prendre
des choix différents d'une élection
alors qu'il faut être présent pour
discuter avec eux on s'est réuni on
bloque aussi avec leur chien pendant
toute là ça va bien ce qui est surtout
important au niveau du bloc ces deux cas
c'est un peu l'image qu'on a deux vieux
partis bagarreur c'est pas tout le monde
qui si importants qu'on a un nouveau
chef pour nos horaires resserrer les
rangs aussi autour de ce chef là ne me
connaissez le npd vous connaissez non
pas nécessairement plus qu'on prend le
temps pour parler aux électeurs et
électrices plus que ça sera en notre
faveur
boscher notre nouveau chef était pas le
tfa là il ya quatre ans le parti
conservateur
il ya dans mon comté en tout cas il y en
a beaucoup plus confiance
je suis la candidate du npd suit la
relève d' hélène laverdière
je vous souhaite de gagner vos élections
ni rancune m'excuser à l'avance parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous à challes et cet
automne pendant la campagne
je suis dans cl au cours des prochaines
semaines oui ça combats ont regardé la
même approche mais avec un raid beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus accéléré décoller que
la campagne est déclenché et nous on est
à 100% à temps plein sur le terrain plus
l'échéance électorale s'approche plus
les gens veulent en parler aussi
effectivement rencontré le plus de monde
possible dans toutes les circonstances
[Applaudissements]